>>Students: Uno, dos,
tres [clapping]...
>>Narrator: At the Bank
Street College of Education
in Manhattan playing hand
games is part of an effort
to teach language skills.
Since 1960 Bank Street has been
making classroom learning meaningful
by connecting it
with student-centered
real-world experiences.
>>Costa-Garro: There's been
a study by anthropologists
and linguists trying to find how
we can connect what is natural
in language development with school.
So what I'm trying to
get the teachers to see
that these hand games can be
integrated into the curriculum.
>>Video: [students counting
in foreign language
along with hand game]
>>Snyder: In the graduate school,
we've stood for something
that's different
in the world of teacher education.
And as opposed to starting
with, "Here's the content.
Now open up your head and
we'll just pour this in
and we'll test you to
see if you have it.
It's a very different starting point
to say, "Let's get an experience
that you're really interested in
that's going to open your own head."
And that takes a real
talented teacher.
>>Teacher: So how did you
figure that out, Emanuel?
>>Emanuel: On my fingers.
>>Teacher: You counted
with your fingers?
Show me.
>>Narrator: Bank Street thinks
talented teachers are developed
by connecting with kids.
>>Teacher: What's that for?
>>Narrator: So they
created laboratory schools
within their teaching facility.
The Family Center serves
the Pre-K set.
>>Boy: We need all the
pieces to make a building.
>>Teacher 3: We need all the pieces?
>>Narrator: And in the
K-8 School for Children,
student teachers work every day
with master teachers by their side.
>>Teacher: So the first
question is whether
or not there's a beginning
of the story?
>>Boy: The beginning was when
the frogs were on the thing,
or when the weasel was there...
>>Teacher: The weasel?
>>Boy: Like there's a weasel
at the very, very beginning.
That's when...
>>Teacher: Did I already
skip the weasel?
>>Snyder: Really it's about engaging
kids in experiences so that they say,
"Hm, I wonder why that happened?"
And then in the midst of
answering that question,
that's a real question based upon
their real experience, they learn how
to read, write, do arithmetic as
well as how to think critically
and to do research and
to get along with others.
>>Teacher: Does anyone have something
different that your group said?
>>Snyder: We try to do the same
thing with our graduate students.
The experiences we engage
them in are teaching kids.
And so they teach kids all day, and
then they come and we say, "Okay.
What happened?
Why do you think that happened?
What do you need to know to
make that go better tomorrow?"
>>Teacher: All right, how
do you think that went?
>>Student Teacher: I think that
it actually went really well.
I mean, we kind of
had time constraints,
but a lot of people wanted to
contribute to the discussion, so.
>>Teacher: Yeah.
>>Narrator: To prepare
new teachers for work
in challenging urban environments,
Bank Street partners with schools
like PS65, an under-resourced
elementary school in the Bronx,
that's now thriving with Bank
Street graduate Tashon McKeithen
at the helm.
>>McKeithan: One thing
that I learned from my time
at Bank Street is really just
the relationships that you build
with students,
and the social/emotional
aspect is really important.
I think once you make
those connections,
everything sort of falls into place.
>>Liverpool: What shape
is this one right here?
>>Girl: A circle.
>>Liverpool: A circle!
>>Narrator: Second year
Bank Street student,
Steve Liverpool landed a job
teaching pre-kindergarten at PS65.
>>Liverpool: Out of these two
objects, which one is a circle?
>>Narrator: While flying solo for the
most part, and learning on the job,
he relies on Bank Street
faculty for continuing support.
>>Liverpool: Can you show
me which one's a circle?
Oh, does that look
like a circle, Natasha?
But that's close.
A circle is round.
Okay, thank you, Miss Betsy.
Natasha looked a little deeper than
what the actual object appears.
What's on it!
Very good.
Mr. Liverpool was looking
just at the content, totally.
>>I was so caught up and Miss
Betsy, she knew where I was going,
and totally just honed in on what
she was saying, and I was like,
"Oh, yeah, there it is, too."
We want them to see
outside of the box.
Not just a regular a
circle is a circle.
It can be more than that.
>>What color is that, boys and girls?
>>Class: Blue!
>>Liverpool: Blue!
>>I had each child
take a turn to show me
which of the objects was a circle.
And then afterwards we broke,
and went around the room,
just walking with a
partner to look for circles.
>>Brown-Franklyn: Okay, so
they'll begin to see circles
in everything that they do.
>>We want to support our students,
so we stay with them for a year,
and I work with them
weekly in their classrooms.
So I come and I meet with them,
I observe what they're doing.
I help them to think further and
deeper around their work with kids.
And I'm their cheerleader.
>>So we could really
do a lot with that
when we come back into the classroom.
We can think about how we can
go from circles to other shapes.
>>My role is to think, "Okay,
so what are we doing next week?
What are we doing next month?
How is this related?"
And so they go, "Oh, okay.
Yeah, maybe we should connect
the circles to the pumpkins
to the apples, because we're
going to go on an apple trip
and we're still doing circles."
>>Liverpool: Anybody else
needs help with their milk?
>>Brown-Franklyn: I think Bank
Street realized that if you want
to place teachers in urban
education, you have to do more
than just educate them theoretically.
You have to give them
practical support.
There's really no other way,
I think, to be successful
at keeping people in
schools like these.
>>Teacher: So let's see if we
can help each other balance.
>>Narrator: Bank Street
encourages teachers
to put their personal
stamp on their classroom.
For recent graduate, Kiera Morton,
that means teaching
first graders yoga.
>>Morton: Fly like a butterfly.
>>Class: Fly like a butterfly.
>>Morton: Sting like a bee.
>>Class: Sting like a bee.
>>Morton: One of my favorite courses
was Music and Movement, obviously.
I really felt that it was that class
that I was able to start thinking,
"Hey, I can actually do yoga
in the classroom with my kids."
>>Sit nice and tall.
Bring your hands on your belly.
Breathe in.
>>Teacher: Trying to build a
lesson plan around reading,
but I have to motivate them to do
this, and I also have to get them
to start thinking about it.
So you're going to take
the stickies that are
on the table, those Post-Its.
And you are now going to go on
a gallery walk out in the hall.
>>Narrator: At Bank Street, learning
is a process of constructing meaning
from personal experience.
For new teachers and
their future students,
it is a demanding enterprise that
goes beyond teaching to the test.
>>Snyder: It takes a great deal of
confidence in yourself as a teacher,
and a great deal of faith in
children, that they're capable
of learning what's on the test,
when you're not telling them
what the answer is on the test.
Fortunately, we now have 90
years of history that says
if you have a really talented
teacher, a really expertly prepared
and supported teacher,
then the kids do better.
>>Liverpool: Okay, everyone
can see Mr. Liverpool?
>>Class: Yes!
>>Liverpool: Yes, and
I can see you, too.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to edutopia.org.